Stanley Kubrick's The Shining is a
masterpiece
as a result some details in the film
that seem out of place serve to
illustrate the supernatural forces at
work in the Overlook other
inconsistencies can't be dismissed so
easily here are a few dumb things in the
shining that we just can't ignore the
creepy sets and confusing layout of the
Overlook Hotel are a central part of the
plot of The Shining the halls are a
labyrinth and the feeling of being lost
and isolated with no idea what's around
the next corner is a key part of what
makes everything so scary this
mysterious feeling is mirrored by the
hedge maze outside and while it's only
fitting that the climax of the film
takes place there the location is
established very early on just not as
early as it should have been the opening
scene of the film gives the audience an
aerial view of the Overlook in the
grounds including the hotel itself the
surrounding forests and the mountains in
the distance the feeling of isolation is
there reinforcing the idea that this is
the kind of place where no one can hear
you scream for help
eagle-eyed viewers will notice that
there's something missing though the
hedge maze is supposed to be right next
to the hotel just a short walk away from
the entrance but in the shot that
establishes our setting it's nowhere to
be found despite the fact that it's
enormous and would definitely be visible
from the sky maybe it just sprung up as
a product of Jack's increasing madness
or maybe the curse at the heart of the
Overlook just really likes metaphors
before officially accepting the
caretaker job jack goes back to the
Overlook for an interview at first it's
pretty standard with mr. Ullman the
manager telling him all about the job
and his potential responsibilities he
warns him about just how far away from
civilization he'll really be explaining
there's basically nothing to do outside
of the hotel and that he and his family
will be alone he then drops what might
be the biggest red flag that any job
interview has ever had while discussing
how the previous caretaker lost the job
killed his family with max almond also
mentions in passing that although
they're in Colorado there's no skiing in
the area clearly this is just to
reinforce the idea that there's no quick
way off the mountain but it's
contradicted by the film itself it's
tough to spot but in those aerial shots
at the beginning of the film you can see
a ski lift going up the side of a
mountain not far from the hotel before
the events of the film take place Jack
Torrance came home drunk one night and
dislocated Danny's shoulder he then
promised that he wouldn't touch alcohol
ever again Wendy tells Danny's doctor
about the incident saying that it's been
five months since Danny's injury and so
far jack has stayed true to his word
perhaps unsurprisingly however Jack
later makes a comment that doesn't match
up with Wendy's timeline when he's
sitting at the bar in the gold room and
griping to the bartender Lloyd about
what happened he says that it all went
down three years ago there are a couple
of possible explanations for this the
most obvious is that it's just a minor
mistake in the script which makes sense
given how many drafts The Shining went
through before it was filmed with
Kubrick behind the camera though there's
also a chance that this was totally
intentional maybe jack is disconnecting
from time as the isolation of the
Overlook drives and Matt maybe he's
remembering an incident from Grady's
life not his own or maybe in the most
disturbing possibility that incident a
few months ago wasn't the only time that
Jack hurt Danny and he doesn't even
remember the more recent abuse when Jack
visits the Gold Room and meets Lloyd the
bartender we're not sure if Boyd is a
ghost or a projection of Jack's twisted
mind regardless Jack strikes up a
conversation with him and orders himself
a bourbon on the rocks he drinks
throughout his rant about how Wendy
won't forgive him for his abuse of Danny
and when Wendy actually arrives in the
Gold Room crying about a mysterious
woman who tried to strangle Danny
Lloyd suddenly disappears along with all
of the liquor and decor behind the bar
it's a genuinely unsettling scene but
either someone in the props department
got a little mixed up or Lloyd isn't
actually the best bartender from
Timbuktu to Portland Maine or Portland
Oregon instead of the Bourbon he asked
for Lloyd pours Jack and drank from a
bottle of Jack Daniels old number 7
which isn't quite what he asked for
while Jack Daniels is legally classified
as straight bourbon the distillery never
markets it or refers to it as anything
but whiskey Lloyd's technically correct
our drinker like Jack Torrance would
definitely know the difference between a
Tennessee whiskey and a Kentucky Bourbon
even in Colorado as the Torrance family
drives to the Overlook we see that
they're traveling in a small yellow
Volkswagen Beetle the shots from inside
the car revealed that while it's fairly
cramped space there is at least enough
room for Danny to move around later in
the lobby of the Overlook however Jack
gestures to the family's huge pile of
luggage sitting by the door Jack Wendy
and Danny are staying at the Overlook
for months and there won't be anywhere
for them to go shopping
so they definitely need all their
clothes if they were really making that
journey in a fee W beetle though there's
no way they could have crammed their
entire wardrobe in the car and still had
room to breathe even with the creepy
space pending geography of the Overlook
there's only so much that a Volkswagen
can hold unless they also bought their
car from an ancient cursed burial ground
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one